Vous avez tous vu beaucoup d'articles sur le changement climatique,
voici un article de plus du New York Times,
identique à tous ceux que vous avez déjà vus.
Il dit exactement les mêmes choses que tous les autres articles.
Il a même un titre de longueur identique.
Ce qui est inhabituel avec celui-ci, peut-être, c'est qu'il date de 1953.
Et la raison pour laquelle je vous raconte ça
c'est que vous avez peut-être l'impression que ce problème est relativement récent.
Que les gens viennent à peine de le comprendre, et maintenant
avec les accords de Kyoto et le 'Gouvernator' Schwartzenegger et les gens qui commencent à réellement faire quelque chose,
nous nous dirigeons peut-être vers une solution.
Le fait est: pas vraiment.
Voilà 50 ans que nous connaissons ce problème, selon comment vous calculez.
Nous n'avons pas cessé d'en parler ces dix dernières années.
Et nous n'avons quasiment rien fait.
Voici le taux d'accroissement du CO2 dans l'atmosphère.
Vous l'avez déjà vu sous différentes formes,
mais peut-être pas cette représentation-là.
Cela montre que le taux de croissance de nos émissions s'accélère.
Et qu'il accélère encore plus
que dans ce que nous pensions être le pire scénario il y a seulement quelques années en arrière.
Beaucoup de sceptiques ont dit que les écologistes
ajoutaient cette ligne rouge dans les projections
uniquement pour les faire apparaître aussi mauvaises que possible.
Que les émissions n'augmenteraient jamais aussi vite que la ligne rouge.
Mais en fait elles augmentent plus vite.
Voici quelques données qui datent de seulement 10 jours,
qui montrent le minimum de glace de l'Arctique cette année, et c'est de loin le plus bas.
La vitesse à laquelle la glace de l'Arctique disparaît est beaucoup plus rapide que les modélisations.
Donc, malgré toutes sortes d'experts comme moi, qui volent aux quatre coins de la planète et
en brûlant du kérosène et des politiciens qui signent des traités,
en fait, on pourrait soutenir que le résultat final de tout cela a été négatif
parce que ça a seulement consommé beaucoup de kérosène. (Rires)
Non, non! Ce que nous devons vraiment faire pour mettre un frein à
cette chose très inertielle - notre grande économie - nous venons à peine de le commencer.
Vraiment, voilà ce que nous faisons en gros. Vraiment, pas grand chose.
Je ne veux pas trop vous déprimer.
Le problème est absolument résoluble, et même d'une façon raisonnablement peu coûteuse.
Le coût étant en gros celui de l'armée, pas celui des soins médicaux.
Représentant quelques pourcents du PIB.
Non, c'est vraiment important d'avoir cette notion d'échelle.
Donc on peut résoudre le problème, et la façon dont nous devrions le résoudre, est, disons,
de s'attaquer à la production d'électricité,
qui génère quelque chose comme environ 43% des émissions de CO2, et ce chiffre est en augmentation.
Nous pourrions le faire avec des moyens tout-à-fait raisonnables comme la maîtrise de l'énergie,
et l'énergie éolienne, l'énergie nucléaire et la capture du CO2 provenant de la combustion du charbon,
qui sont toutes prêtes à être déployées à grande échelle et qui marchent.
Tout ce qui manque, c'est de vraiment dépenser de l'argent pour les mettre en place.
Au lieu de passer notre temps à parler.
Mais néanmoins, ce n'est pas ce dont je vais vous parler ce soir.
Je vais vous parler ce soir de ce que nous pourrions faire si nous ne faisons rien.
Ce truc ici au milieu est ce que vous faites
si vous n'arrêtez pas les émissions assez rapidement.
Vous devez vous en occuper - en quelque sorte briser le lien entre les actions humaines
qui changent le climat, et le changement climatique lui-même. Et c'est particulièrement important
car bien sûr, alors que nous pouvons nous adapter au changement climatique --
et il est important d'être honnête ici - il y aura des avantages au changement climatique.
Oh oui, je pense que c'est mauvais. J'ai passé toute ma vie à travailler pour y mettre un terme.
Mais une des raisons pour lesquelles c'est politiquement difficile est qu'il y a des gagnants et des perdants - pas que des perdants.
Mais bien sûr, la nature, les ours polaires.
J'ai passé plusieurs semaines d'affilée à skier sur la mer gelée dans le haut Arctique.
Ils vont perdre complètement.
Et il n'y a pas d'adaptation.
On peut absolument résoudre le problème.
Cette idée de géo-ingénierie, dans sa forme la plus simple, est la suivante :
on pourrait mettre certaines particules, par exemple d'acide sulfurique - des sulfates --
dans la haute atmosphère, la stratosphère,
où elles dévieraient la lumière du soleil et refroidiraient la planète.
Je suis certain que cela fonctionnera.
Non qu'il n'y ait pas d'effets secondaires, mais je suis sûr que ça marchera.
Et la raison en est la suivante: ça a déjà été fait.
Cela n'a pas été fait par nous, ni moi, mais par la nature.
Voici le mont Pinatubo au début des années 90, qui a envoyé tout un tas de soufre
dans la stratosphère, avec un nuage en forme de champignon atomique.
Le résultat a été assez radical.
Après ça, et les éruptions précédentes d'autres volcans, on voit
un refroidissement assez radical de l'atmosphère.
Donc, cette courbe inférieure représente la haute atmosphère, la stratosphère,
elle chauffe après ces éruptions.
Mais vous remarquerez que dans la courbe supérieure, qui représente la basse atmosphère
et la surface, elle refroidit parce que nous avons un peu protégé l'atmosphère.
Ce n'est pas un grand mystère.
Il y a beaucoup de mystère dans les détails, et il y a de mauvais effets secondaires,
comme la destruction partielle de la couche d'ozone - et j'y viendrai dans une minute.
Mais clairement, ça refroidit.
Autre chose : c'est rapide.
Il est vraiment important de le dire. Tant d'autres choses que nous devrions faire,
comme ralentir les émissions, sont intrinsèquement lentes car il faut du temps
pour construire tout le matériel dont nous avons besoin.
Et pas seulement ça, lorsque vous réduisez les émissions, vous n'arrêtez pas les concentrations.
A cause des concentrations, la quantité de CO2 dans l'air,
est la somme des émissions dans le temps.
Vous ne pouvez donc pas freiner d'un coup.
Mais si vous faites cela, c'est rapide.
Et il y a des fois où vous aimeriez faire quelque chose vite.
Vous vous demandez aussi peut-être, est-ce que ça marche?
Est-ce qu'on peut réduire l'ensoleillement et compenser efficacement le CO2 supplémentaire,
et produire un climat qui revienne en quelque sorte à son état d'origine?
La réponse semble être oui.
Voici les courbes que vous avez déjà vues souvent.
Voilà à quoi ressemble le monde vu sous une modélisation particulière du climat
avec deux fois la quantité de CO2 dans l'air.
Le graphique inférieur présente deux fois la quantité de CO2 et 1,8 % moins d'ensoleillement,
et on revient au climat d'origine.
Nous devons ces graphiques à Ken Caldera. C'est important de le dire parce que
Ken, lors d'une réunion à laquelle je crois Marty Hoffart assistait également dans le milieu des années 90 --
Ken et moi nous sommes levés au fond de la salle et avons dit,
"La géo-ingénierie ne marchera pas."
A la personne qui en faisait la promotion, ça disait,
"L'atmosphère est beaucoup plus compliquée que ça."
On a donné un tas de raisons physiques pour lesquelles il n'y aurait pas une bonne compensation.
Ken est parti lancer ses modélisations, et a trouvé le contraire.
Ce sujet date également.
Ce rapport a atterri sur le bureau du Président Johnson quand j'avais deux ans.
1965.
Ce rapport, en fait, contenait toute la science moderne sur le climat --
la seule solution qui y était évoquée était la géo-ingénierie.
Il ne parlait même pas de réduction des émissions,
qui est un incroyable changement dans notre réflexion sur ce sujet.
Je ne dis pas que nous ne devons pas réduire les émissions.
Nous le devrions, mais il parlait précisément de ça.
Donc, en un sens, il n'y a pas grand chose de nouveau.
La seule chose nouvelle est cet essai.
Donc, je dois dire, je suppose, que depuis le temps du rapport originel au Président Johnson,
et les différents rapports de l'Académie Nationale américaine --
1977, 1982, 1990 - les gens ont toujours parlé de cette idée.
Pas comme quelque chose d'infaillible, mais comme une idée à méditer.
Mais quand le climat est devenu, au plan politique, un sujet brûlant - si je peux me permettre le jeu de mots --
au cours des 15 dernières années, le sujet est devenu si politiquement incorrect que nous ne pouvions pas en parler.
Il était enterré. Nous n'avions pas le droit d'en parler.
Mais au cours de l'année dernière, Paul Crutzen a publié cet essai
qui disait en gros tout ce qui avait été dit auparavant: que, peut-être, compte tenu du rythme très lent
des progrès que nous faisions sur ce problème, et des impacts incertains,
nous devions penser à des choses comme celle-là.
Il a dit en gros ce qui avait été dit auparavant.
La différence : il avait gagné le Prix Nobel pour ses recherches sur la chimie de l'ozone.
Les gens l'ont donc pris au sérieux quand il a dit que nous devrions y réfléchir,
même s'il y avait certaines incidences sur l'ozone.
En fait, il a quelques idées pour s'en débarrasser.
Il y a eu tous types d'articles de journaux, dans le monde entier,
qui allaient jusqu'à ce titre "Le Docteur Folamour Sauve la Terre," dans The Economist.
Ça m'a donné à réfléchir - j'ai travaillé sur ce thème par intermittence,
mais pas tant techniquement - j'étais couché dans mon lit en train de réfléchir une nuit.
J'ai pensé à ce jouet pour enfant - d'où le titre de mon allocution --
et je me demandais si on pouvait utiliser la même physique qui fait tourner cette chose
dans le radiomètre de l'enfant pour faire léviter des particules dans la haute atmosphère
et les y faire rester.
Un des problèmes avec les sulfates est qu'ils tombent rapidement.
L'autre problème est qu'ils sont en plein dans la couche d'ozone,
et je préfèrerais qu'ils en soient au-dessus.
Finalement, je me suis réveillé le lendemain matin, et j'ai commencé à calculer ça.
C'est très difficile à calculer à partir des premiers principes. J'ai été déconcerté.
Mais ensuite j'ai découvert qu'il y avait toutes sortes de documents déjà publiés
qui avaient abordé ce sujet parce que ça se produit déjà dans l'atmosphère naturelle.
Il semble donc qu'il existe déjà de fines particules
qui lévitent jusqu'à ce que l'on appelle la mésosphère, à environ 100 kilomètres d'altitude --
qui ont déjà cet effet.
Je vais vous dire très rapidement comment l'effet se produit.
Il y a beaucoup de difficultés amusantes
sur lesquelles j'adorerais passer toute la soirée, mais je ne le ferai pas.
Mais disons que la lumière du soleil frappe une particule qui est ainsi chauffée de façon inégale.
Le côté face au soleil est plus chaud, et l'autre beaucoup plus froid.
Des molécules de gaz qui rebondissent sur le côté chaud
s'éloignent avec une vitesse accrue à cause de la chaleur.
Vous avez une force nette qui s'éloigne du soleil.
On l'appelle la force photophorétique.
Il en existe un tas d'autres versions, par moi et d'autres,
sur comment l'exploiter.
Bien sûr, nous avons peut-être tort --
tout ça n'a pas encore été soumis à nos pairs, nous sommes en train d'y réfléchir --
mais jusqu'à présent, ça semble bien.
Mais il semble que nous pourrions atteindre de longues durées de vie atmosphériques --
beaucoup plus longues qu'avant - parce qu'elles ont lévité.
Nous pouvons déplacer des choses de la stratosphère à la mésosphère,
et en principe résoudre le problème de l'ozone.
Je suis sûr qu'il y aura d'autres problèmes qui se poseront.
Enfin, nous avons pu faire migrer les particules au-dessus des pôles,
afin de pouvoir organiser l'ingénierie climatique pour qu'elle s'y concentre vraiment.
Ce qui aurait un minimum d'impacts négatifs sur l'endroit de la planète
où nous vivons et ferait le maximum de ce qu'on pourrait avoir besoin de faire --
c'est-à-dire refroidir les pôles en cas d'urgence planétaire, si vous voulez.
Il s'agit d'une idée nouvelle qui a germé et qui est peut-être essentiellement
une meilleure idée que d'envoyer des sulfates.
Que cette idée soit la bonne ou qu'une autre idée soit la bonne,
je crois qu'il est quasiment sûr que nous finirons
par trouver mieux que d'envoyer du soufre.
Que, si les ingénieurs et les chercheurs se mettent vraiment à y réfléchir,
nous pouvons influer sur la planète d'une façon incroyable.
Ce qui compte dans tout ça, c'est que ça nous donne un levier extraordinaire.
Cette amélioration de la science et de l'ingénierie, qu'on le veuille ou non,
nous donnera de plus en plus de levier pour influer sur la planète.
Pour contrôler la planète.
Pour nous donner le contrôle de la météo et du climat - non pas parce que nous le planifions,
non pas parce que nous le voulons, simplement parce que la science nous le livre petit à petit,
avec une meilleure connaissance du fonctionnement du système
de meilleurs outils d'ingénierie pour le mettre en œuvre.
Maintenant, supposons que des extraterrestres arrivent --
peut-être vont-ils atterrir au siège de l'ONU tout près d'ici,
ou peut-être qu'ils choisiront un endroit plus intelligent --
mais supposons qu'ils arrivent et nous donnent une boîte.
La boîte a deux boutons.
Un bouton est le bouton de contrôle de la température de la planète.
Peut-être que l'autre bouton est un bouton de contrôle des concentrations de CO2.
Vous imaginez sans problème que nous battrions pour cette boîte.
Parce que nous n'avons aucun moyen de nous entendre pour savoir où fixer les boutons.
Nous n'avons pas de gouvernance mondiale.
Différentes personnes voudront la mettre dans différents endroits.
Maintenant, je ne pense pas que ça arrive. Ce n'est pas très probable.
Mais nous construisons cette boîte.
Les scientifiques et les ingénieurs du monde
la construisent pièce par pièce, dans leurs laboratoires.
Même s'ils le font pour d'autres raisons.
Même s'ils pensent simplement travailler sur la protection de l'environnement.
Ils n'ont aucun intérêt pour des idées folles comme l'ingénierie de la planète entière.
Ils développent la science qui rend l'action de plus en plus facile.
Mon avis sur cette question n'est pas que je veux le faire - je ne le veux pas --
mais que nous devons sortir cette question de l'ombre et en parler sérieusement.
Parce que tôt ou tard nous allons être confrontés à des décisions à ce sujet,
et c'est mieux si l'on y réfléchit bien,
même si l'on veut réfléchir à des raisons pour lesquelles nous ne devrions jamais le faire.
Je vais vous donner deux manières différentes de réfléchir à ce problème qui sont le début
de mes réflexions sur la façon d'y penser.
Nous avons besoin que ce ne soit pas seulement quelques hurluberlus comme moi qui y réfléchissent --
il nous faut un débat plus large.
Un débat qui implique des musiciens, des scientifiques, des philosophes, des écrivains,
qui s'attaquent à cette question sur l'ingénierie climatique
et réfléchissent sérieusement à ses implications.
Alors, voici une façon de penser,
qui est de faire cela au lieu de réduire les émissions, car c'est moins cher.
Ce que je n'ai pas dit à ce sujet, c'est que c'est ridiculement bon marché.
Il est concevable que, par exemple, en utilisant la méthode des sulfates ou cette méthode que j'ai inventée,
on puisse créer un âge glaciaire pour un coût de 0,0001 % du PIB.
C'est très bon marché. Nous avons beaucoup d'effet de levier.
Ce n'est pas une bonne idée, mais c'est juste important.
Je vais vous dire l'importance du levier - le levier est grand comme ça.
Et ce calcul n'est pas tellement discutable.
Vous pourriez trouver que c'est insensé, mais l'effet de levier est réel. (Rires)
Donc, de ce fait, nous avons pu régler le problème
simplement en cessant de réduire les émissions.
et alors que les concentrations augmentent, nous pouvons augmenter
la quantité de géo-ingénierie.
Je ne pense pas que quiconque prenne ça au sérieux.
Parce que dans ce scénario, on s'éloigne de plus en plus
du climat actuel.
Nous avons toutes sortes d'autres problèmes tels que l'acidification des océans
qui découlent du CO2 dans l'atmosphère de toute façon.
Personne, sauf peut-être une ou deux personnes très étranges suggèrent vraiment cela.
Voici un cas qui est plus difficile à rejeter.
Disons que nous ne faisons pas de géo-ingénierie, nous faisons ce que nous devons faire,
c'est-à-dire nous mettre sérieusement à réduire les émissions.
Mais nous ne savons pas vraiment à quelle vitesse nous devons les réduire.
Il y a beaucoup d'incertitude quant à savoir exactement si le changement climatique est trop important.
Donc, disons que nous travaillons dur, et nous ne nous contentons pas de mettre le pied sur le frein,
mais nous freinons à fond et réduisons réellement les émissions
et finalement nous réduisons les concentrations.
Et peut-être un jour - par exemple le 23 octobre 2075 --
nous arriverons enfin à ce jour glorieux où les concentrations auront atteint leur sommet
et commenceront à redescendre.
Et nous fêterons ça dans le monde entier, et nous aurons réellement commencé à - vous savez -
le pire est derrière nous.
Mais peut-être ce jour-là, nous aurons également constaté que la calotte glaciaire du Groenland
fond vraiment trop vite, assez vite pour élever le niveau de la mer de
plusieurs mètres pour les 100 prochaines années,
et rayer certaines des plus grandes villes de la carte.
C'est un scénario tout à fait possible.
Nous pourrions décider à ce moment-là, même si la géo-ingénierie est incertaine
et moralement malheureuse, que c'est beaucoup mieux que pas de géo-ingénierie.
C'est une manière très différente d'aborder le problème.
Il s'agit de l'utiliser pour contrôler le risque et non pour agir.
Vous faites un peu de géo-ingénierie pendant quelque temps
pour supprimer le plus gros de la chaleur, et pas pour éviter d'agir.
Mais cette approche pose un problème.
Le problème est le suivant:
le fait de savoir la géo-ingénierie possible fait
que les incidences du climat semblent moins redoutables.
Cela engendre une volonté plus faible à réduire les émissions aujourd'hui.
C'est ce que les économistes appellent l'aléa moral.
C'est une des raisons fondamentales qui fait qu'il est si difficile de parler de ce problème,
et, en général, je pense que c'est la raison sous-jacente
qui a fait qu'il est politiquement inacceptable d'en parler.
Mais on ne fait pas de bonne politique en cachant les choses.
Je vais vous laisser avec trois questions, puis une dernière citation.
Faut-il faire des recherches sérieuses sur ce sujet?
Nous faut-il un programme national de recherche qui s'y intéresse?
Pas seulement à la façon de mieux le faire,
mais aussi à tous les risques et les inconvénients que cela comporte.
Vous avez déjà quelques amateurs qui en parlent, certains d'une façon positive,
certains d'une façon négative - mais c'est une position dangereuse
parce qu'il y a très peu de connaissances approfondies sur ce sujet.
Une très petite somme d'argent nous en donnerait.
Beaucoup d'entre nous - peut-être moi maintenant - pensent que nous devrions le faire.
Mais j'ai de nombreuses réserves.
J'ai essentiellement des réserves quant au problème d'aléa moral,
et je ne sais pas vraiment comment nous pouvons éviter l'éviter au mieux.
Je pense qu'il y a un sérieux problème quand on en parle.
Les gens commencent à penser qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de travailler si dur pour réduire les émissions.
Autre chose : peut-être avons-nous besoin d'un traité.
Un traité qui décide à qui il revient de le faire.
Pour le moment, nous pensons peut-être à un grand pays riche comme les États-Unis pour s'en charger.
Mais il se pourrait bien que, en fait, si la Chine se réveille en 2030 et se rend compte
que les impacts climatiques sont inacceptables,
elle ne soit pas intéressée par nos conversations morales sur comment s'y prendre,
et qu'elle décide simplement qu'elle préfère avoir un monde de géo-ingénierie
qu'un monde de non-géo-ingénierie.
Nous n'aurons pas de système international pour savoir qui prend la décision.
Alors, voici une dernière pensée, qui a été beaucoup mieux exprimée
il y a 25 ans dans le rapport de l'Académie Nationale Américaine que je ne peux le faire aujourd'hui.
Et je pense que cela résume bien où nous en sommes ici.
Le problème du CO2, le problème du climat dont nous avons entendu parler,
est le moteur de beaucoup de choses, d'innovations dans les technologies énergétiques,
qui permettront de réduire les émissions.
Mais aussi, je pense inévitablement que ça nous conduira à réfléchir au contrôle du climat
et de la météo que ça nous plaise ou non.
Et il est temps de commencer à y réfléchir,
même si la raison pour laquelle nous réfléchissons, c'est pour construire des arguments
pour dire pourquoi nous ne devrions pas le faire.
Merci beaucoup.